Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim und ja die sechsundzwanzigster ausgabe,
heute ist kein corona weekly das kommt dann später danach
heute geht's aber trotzdem nochmal um das permanente dauerthema wie sollte es auch anderes sein aber wollen jetzt mal eine zwischendurch mal eine ganz andere perspektive einnehmen oder vielleicht nicht eine ganz andere perspektive
so eine perspektive die uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen.
Gefehlt hat im gesamtkontext nämlich die perspektive der gesundheitsämtern sprich jetzt allerdings nicht mehr im gesundheitsamt sondern ich spreche mit dem oliver oliver droht boom hallo oli.
Moin du bist entwickler kann man sagen ne wahrscheinlich auch schon ziemlich lange oder.
Ich hatte vor kurzem zehnjähriges firmenjubiläum und davor habe ich auch schon wie eine weile gearbeitet also seit zwanzig jahren ist ungefähr ja.
Womit beschäftigst du dich normalerweise so.
Ich bin hauptsächlich in einem team aktiv was o pen source software interessanterweise betreibt also auf bezahlte art und weise wir haben da so ein anfang der zweitausender so ein framework gefunden was in der welt relativ große verbreitung gefunden hat das bringt framework.
Und bin da im engineering team und also entwickelt das framework weiter beziehungsweise hilft dann auch relativ regelmäßig in welchen kunden.
Das dann entsprechend einzusetzen und applikationen damit zu bauen genau.
Das kommt ja wenn ich das richtig sehe auch gerade bei dieser corona warn-app zum einsatz.
Das haben wir gestern auch erfahren und festgestellt sind seitdem im regen austausch mit der sap und den entsprechenden leuten vielleicht können wir da ein bisschen unterstützen.
Weiterhelfen aber ja also es war gestern große große über nicht überraschungen zwingender weise von uns weil wir wussten dass die sap dinge mit tut beziehungsweise auch mit blut also springt framework und.
Ja da also da wird eben die gleiche technologie eingesetzt beziehungsweise über das was ihr dann heute noch sprechen wollen.
Oder da jetzt sehr darauf fokussieren zu wollen aber was macht dieses es bringt fremdwort wofür ist das da.
Na ja das ist ein üblicherweise mein applikationen entwickelt
wenn man bestimmte technische dinge einfach nicht von von neu bauen also irgendwelche datenbank transaktionen security solche themen werden einem halt einfach leicht gemacht die umzusetzen da gibt's halt einen großen großen baustein an bibliotheken
oder einen großen satz an bibliotheken bausteinen
im entwicklern zur verfügung stellen und je nachdem welches problem sie dann haben wählen sie da werden sie dann eben diese bibliotheken aus um technische details lösen zu können damit sie sich selbst wiederum
eher darauf fokussieren können was eigentlich das domänen problem ist es gibt eigentlich in jeder programmiersprache in javascript ja sowieso und auch halt eben in der welt und dieses hat sich halt relativ weit verbreitet ist.
Großes framework was von bankenversicherung apple netflix den üblichen verdächtigen und so eingesetzt wird für ihre software.
Okay also für dich ist das alles kein kein neuland warum wir jetzt miteinander sprechen ist weil du mit dem kollegen zusammen jetzt gerade dabei bist eine andere software im ganzen korona kontext zu
entwickeln wie kam es dazu was wir hat das alles sein lauf genommen.
Also ich bin am anfang april von einem ehemaligen kollegen von mir kontaktiert worden wir haben früher zusammen in der firma gearbeitet der meinte wir haben an diesem hackathlon teilgenommen in diesem bierbörse virus hackathon.
Der irgendwie ein oder zwei wochen vorher stattgefunden hatte und sie hätten da ein stückchen software dass ich eben damit beschäftigt die arbeit von gesundheitsämtern,
zu vereinfachen in bezug auf diese kurve neunzehn problematik und das nachverfolgen von von den kontaktstellen also.
Getesteten personen beziehungsweise ihren kontakten und sie hätten da was und wir haben das gebaut
an dem wochenende und sie hätten jetzt auch ein gesundheitsamtes dezidiert interesse daran hat diese software einzusetzen und die eben unterstützung gesucht haben in der
produktiv dieses dieses prototypen also da war so ein bisschen coach und da der sah dementsprechend also auch natürlich hin gebote typ aus und wir haben dann eben angefangen.
Den nach und nach irgendwie.
Produktionsleiter zu bauen und noch mehr features hinzuzufügen und so weiter und so fort aber ausgangspunkt war eben dieser dieser wir vivers ist virus heike.
Das hier ist selber konkret nicht daran teilgenommen sondern eben dein kollege was hast du so mitbekommen davon wie das da gelaufen ist.
Also ich habe halt von dem von dem hackathon mitbekommen wir haben halt gesehen dass da dinge passieren habe selbst irgendwie eigentlich nicht den plan gehabt daran teilzunehmen.
Der also patrick selbst der kollege der eben jetzt hier die die technische seite mit verantwortet
die haben da wohl einfach aus aus spaß an der freude irgendwie einfach teilgenommen also hatten jetzt auch keinen keinen konkreten bezug zu irgendwelchen medizinischen themen vorher oder sowas sondern haben sie einfach
sich da eingebracht haben andere leute auch völlig,
unbekannte leute eben kennengelernt und sind eben auf jemanden gestoßen dort der meinte dass der so ein bisschen wusste wie die gesundheitsämtern arbeiten.
Und das als problemstellung quasi mit in den raum geworfen hat also es gab da wohl zum teil ebenso,
problemverursacher und die haben sich einfach diesen gesundheitsämtern thema angenommen weil.
So wie ich das erfahren habe der der hauptgrund war einfach mal gesagt hat okay da gibt's irgendwie bestimmte dinge die die da aktuell tun.
Sprechen wir sicherlich später noch drüber die relativ leicht in anführungsstrichen zu digitalisieren sind also einfacher,
jetzt vielleicht irgendeine ausgefallene technische lösung ist einfach nur darum geht den ein bisschen arbeit abzunehmen dadurch dass die software einfach unterstützt und dann haben die relativ intensiv mit mit.
Aktuell oder damals infizierten gehabt kontakt gehabt und mit denen gearbeitet.
Um herauszubekommen wie denn eigentlich dieser prozess ausläuft weil's an dem wochenende dieses hackathons gab's noch gar keinen kontakt zu irgendwelchen gesundheitsämtern also wage irgendwie kontakt ketten wo man vielleicht mal weiß wo man jemand fragen kann,
aber hauptsächlich haben die dann eben mit mit
bereits kurve infizierten gesprochen wie das für die gelaufen ist und haben dann quasi halt damit ich herausbekommen was die halt so tagtäglich tun müssen und wie und in welcher form und in welchem umfang die mit den gesundheitsämtern dann in kontakt stehen über die zeit ihrer.
Ihre quarantäne und daraus ist eben dieser prototyp entstanden der eigentlich erstmal die.
Bürger seite wir haben bürger seite und amt seite die bürger seite beleuchtet hat und ausgearbeitet hat also so eine art tagebuch den.
Die infizierten dann eben alle und deren kontaktpersonen alle zweimal am tag eigentlich ausfüllen müssen beziehungsweise damals eben noch telefonisch in fragebogen beantworten jeden tag.
Bevor wir da vielleicht im detail noch mal drauf eingehen
was hast du so gehört wie das gelaufen ist bei diesem hackathlon weil das war ja also erstens war das ja eine sehr sehr kurzfristig anberaumtes geschichte und dann haben viele leute dran teilgenommen und es lief ja alles wird toll.
Und am ende gab es ja auch so ein paar jurys die sich die ganzen missions angeschaut haben und ich glaube es waren sogar alle,
sachen die daran teilgenommen haben sind am ende mit so einem präsentationsvideo auf youtube gelandet sodass man sich das sozusagen dort anschauen konnte.
Ist denn euer projekt an der stelle auch schon irgendeiner form positiv bewertet und ausgewählt worden oder hat sich das vollkommen unabhängig davon entwickelt.
Also da kann ich dir so detailliert gar nichts dazu sagen also zu dem was da jetzt an dem wochenende dann noch genau passiert ist,
wir sind nur in nicht wissen nicht in dieser top zwanzig gelandet aber in so einer in so einer förderpolitik von zweihundert zweihundert projekten die jetzt zum einen weitere finanzielle unterstützung bekommen.
Als auch natürlich also da gibt es ein relativ viel um kontakte und und wer weg
also der kriegt das kriegt davon mit dass es dieses projekt überhaupt gibt es zum beispiel für die für uns hat relativ interessant vor gesundheitsämtern zu kommen aber da gibt es initiativen aus diesem aus diesem hackathon
heraus da gibt's noch irgendwie einen channel immer noch wo man dann eben sich hinwenden kann und sagen kann wir haben jetzt das und das
problem kann uns da irgendwer helfen und da ist quasi einfach ein netzwerk an leuten die die da weiter mit uns arbeiten.
Es gibt wohl demnächst auch eine offizielle ankündigung vom bmw f über die geförderten projekte nochmal die jetzt also weiter gefördert werden.
Ja da gibt's halt weiterhin so entfernten austausch der ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so so intensiv wie er an dem wochenende war also ich persönlich habe jetzt.
Eigentlich davon von dem kontakten doch.
Nicht so richtig was mitbekommen aus es gibt morgen glaube ich im morgen abend irgendwie wieder eine so eine vier wochen sind rum veranstaltungen über zoom aber das beeinflusst jetzt sozusagen die tagtägliche arbeit ist für mich persönlich erstmal nicht die.
Unsere die leute die jetzt im team sind bei uns die sich um diese ganze thematik auftritt marketing und so und verbreitung der sache.
Kümmern die sind da natürlich um die stärker involviert einfach.
Aber immerhin also hat sich da noch relativ schnell so eine community,
gebildet und man hat auch nicht den fehler gemacht so nur so ein one-hit-wonder zu machen um mal gruß dazustehen hier guck mal wir tun was sondern es ist halt wirklich relativ nachhaltig betrieben worden also ich fand das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich bemerkenswert ich meine man ist ja
von
vom staat nicht so viel gewohnt in dieser hinsicht ne trotzdem hat sich glaube ich in diesem ganzen hecke von bereich mit so diversen erfolgreichen projekten
brutal pfand und anderen sagt die ja auch alle in diesem hecke von projekt
engagiert waren einiges getan und hast du das gefühl da kam dann zum richtigen zeitpunkt mal die über die jahre gesammelt erfahrung zusammen um das dann auch wirklich effizient durchführen zu können und das eben dann auch noch online.
Also ich ich bin eigentlich auch eher so ich habe so eine leichte skeptische haltung was diese hackathons angeht weil ich auch immer das gefühl habe so da wird dann über den wochenende was getan und dann danach ist.
Was genau so also dann das ist das entfaltet der eigentlich nur effekt wenn man auch einen plan für danach hat und ich habe,
bei vielen so kleineren hackathons habe ich immer das gefühl gehabt dass deren idee dann am sonntagabend aufhört
jetzt gerade im bezug auf diese kurve neunzehn problematik hatte ich so das das andere gefühl war es fehlt ja eigentlich nicht so sehr an ideen wo unterstützung notwendig ist sondern eigentlich an so
klassischer wir müssen es irgendwie mal machen also wir müssen es wirklich mal zu ende bringen.
Deswegen habe ich dann im nachhinein als patrick mich gefragt hat ob ich lust hätte mitzumachen auch gesagt ja natürlich also wenn's jetzt darum geht das irgendwo produktiv zu kriegen.
Ja das ist jetzt sozusagen das neue also dass dass da eine gewisse nachhaltigkeit ist weil man halt nicht nur gesehen hat so
weil es nicht nur so ein schaulaufen war um um zu zeigen wie geil man ist man wollte halt offensichtlich oder zumindest kam es dann dazu man wollte eben auch wirklich konkrete hilfe haben weil die war ja nun mal erforderlich,
bekämpfen der krise jetzt habe ich hier bei schon sehr viel über diese ganzen tracing apps gesprochen das ist in meinem corolla victorian dauerthema,
einfach weil das aus so vielen.
Richtung her interessant es ist technisch interessant es ist als als als idee
was komplett neues was es so noch nicht gab und alle major player dieser welt sind da sozusagen involviert also die staaten die großen tech-konzerne und so dieser ganze battle der da sich abspielt,
alles ganz aufschlussreich nichtsdestotrotz muss man ja auch nochmal feststellen diese ganze tracing app diskussion,
ist halt das ziel ist halt ein system zu entwickeln was beim normalen contact tracing hilft.
Aber das nicht ersetzt und letztlich seid ihr ja mit eurem projekt jetzt sehr viel näher an dieser tatsächlichen tätigkeit der gesundheitsämtern
was hier anfangs bisschen ich sag mal salopp als quarantäne tagebuch gestartet ist als idee ja also was du als bürger seite bezeichnet bedeutet ja letzten endes nur infizierten wurde.
Kontaktiert vom gesundheitsamt muss jetzt zuhause bleiben also wenn die leute ja nicht akut krank sind dann bleiben sie halt erstmal zuhause oder irgendwo.
Und teil dieser ganzen betreuung dieser infizierten ist auch weiterhin symptome abzufragen,
um einfach zu wissen okay wie entwickelt sich das sind ja auch alle.
A wertvolle daten und b will man natürlich auch diesen leuten die gelegenheit geben,
gegebenenfalls hilfe zu bekommen oder ins krankenhaus zu kommen sollte sich eben die situation zu verschlechtern und es wird natürlich dann auch wieder interessante epidemiologische medizinische informationen et cetera mit sich also da ist viel zu gewinnen für alle seiten
nur es ist eben ein sehr aufwendiger prozess wie seid ihr da jetzt ran gegangen also irgendwann gab es ja dann auch kontakt mit gesundheitsamt.
Genau also nachdem dieser hackathon zu ende war
hatte gab es durch zu verhalten den konkreten kontakt ins gesundheitsamt in mannheim jetzt in dem fall das liegt
bisschen daran dass teile des projektteams in mannheim oder in der gegend verortet sind und man dann so
kennt man jemanden der jemanden kennt und dann haben wir das das projekt dort vorgestellt und waren relativ schnell an dem punkt dass sie gesagt haben ja wenn das ein also
wenn das wird ein wirkliches stück software wird dann würden wir da gerne mit euch zusammen arbeiten um das um da quasi
zu definieren was für features wir brauchen damit wir das sinnvoll einsetzen können und dann haben wir das gemacht und so ein paar paar runden und einfach.
Ganz klassische agiles auf der entwicklung wir bauen ein bisschen was wir fahren zu denen wir zeigen denen das dann funktionieren sachen oder die wir hätten gerne sachen anders und dann darüber ist jetzt sozusagen eigentlich bis jetzt letzte woche.
Einfach so dieses dieses projekt entstanden oder hat sich weiterentwickelt und ist seitdem bei denen im test also es ist sozusagen dass wie sich jetzt seitdem in seitdem hackathon entwickelt hat eigentlich.
Die haben halt vorher auf die art und weise gearbeitet dass es eigentlich
vielleicht noch ein wichtiger punkt die gesundheitsämtern arbeiten alle irgendwie für sich also da gibt es jetzt keinen keinen vorgefertigten prozess wie die so eine so eine quarantäne oder sondern nach verfolgung zu handhaben
haben sondern die haben sich da alle irgendwie organisiert und das ist wie man das halt in so typischen deutschen verwaltung eigentlich findet das ist sehr viel,
ja zum teil halt in die hand geschrieben auf also papier oder halt dann eben wenn man fortschrittlich ist hat man wie excel tabellen.
Und organisiert sich das da so zusammen genau also alle infizierten alle kontaktpersonen tauchen darin auf und ein gesundheit arbeiter hat jetzt quasi die aufgabe dann den entsprechend,
jeden zweimal am tag anzurufen und bestimmte sachen abzufragen mit denen zu sprechen und das dann eben in dem.
Mehr oder weniger digitalisierten oder nicht digitalisierten system zu hinterlegen und dann werden eben diese listen ausgetauscht und dann auch ist ob es gibt mittlerweile so eine schnittstelle vom
dann gehen die schlussendlich als aber die tagtägliche arbeit ist quasi excel so hauptsächlich das ist so der das ende der fahnenstange für die bisher.
Weißt du wie das ist also wenn jetzt eine neue infektion reinkommt.
Ein infizierten quasi erstmalig in kontakt tritt wird den dann mehr oder weniger ein mitarbeiter fest zugeteilt oder ist das so ein pool wie in so einem callcenter wer gerade zeit hat beschäftigt sich mit den.
Da bin ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher ich hatte wir haben mit super zahlen recherchiert also wir hatten in dieser anfangs oder dieser zeit bevor der lok down muss ging so mitte märz,
da gab es dann scheinbar irgendwie weil ich weiß ungefähr tausend personen die von sechsunddreißig,
gesundheitsamt mitarbeiter betreut werden mussten tausend personen heißt nicht tausend infizierte weil das gesundheitsamt muss sich immer um den infizierten oder die infizierten plus alle personen kümmern.
Von denen die wiederum angegeben haben dass sie kontakt mit denen hatten also das ist zum teil sind das leid leute ich sage okay meine familie meine frau meine mutter mein vater,
oder es kann auch noch so sachen sein wie naja ich war halt beim bäcker da also ich habe auf jeden fall mit der mit der bäcker frau da irgendwie
zehn minuten geredet was natürlich dann auch recherchearbeit bedeutet also arbeit die die eigentlich gar nicht so zwingend gewohnt sind zu tun sondern da müssen sie rauskriegen wer ist das wie können wir die erreichen und so weiter und so fort.
Solche themen passieren da ob die jetzt dann.
Aktiv ob da ein einzelner mitarbeiter an so einem fall dranbleibt weiß ich nicht hundertprozentig wir haben auf jeden fall ein feature im system wo sich ein mitarbeiter so ein
einen bestimmten kontakt oder ein eine person zuordnen kann und sagen kann ich möchte mit dem irgendwie also den bearbeite ich jetzt,
einfach weil da oft dann natürlich auch dass wenn man jeden tag jemand anderes anruft ist es irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Ja man muss ja auch ein gefühl für die leute bekommen ich glaube man kann auch nicht unbedingt immer davon ausgehen dass die leute so ohne weiteres kooperativ sind also.
Gründen auch immer weil sie da irgendwie privat
ungern zugeben wollen mit dem mit dem sich da jetzt nochmal einstellig ein gestellt haben oder einfach nur eine grundsätzliche verweigerungshaltung oder einfach leute die auch aus welchen gründen auch immer
kommunikationsprobleme haben oder so ne.
Oh das sind halt einfach leute die jetzt zum beispiel wenn wir jetzt sagen okay wir haben jetzt diese stückchen software da könnt ihr das irgendwie täglich dann für euch tun einfach dieses tagebuch legen es gibt halt leute die können oder schrägstrich wollen das nicht also wenn es irgendwie eine mit der achtzigjährige.
Was auch immer oder ein mit der achtzigjährige ob um gott ich werde jetzt keine keine ältere leute irgendwie aber verstehst du jemand der nicht so technikaffin ist der dann einfach sagt das kann ich nicht will ich nicht aus irgendwelchen gründen dann muss das irgendwie auch gehen wir dann mit.
Mit eingebunden werden oder kostet aber innerhalb mehr zeit entsprechend.
Gibt es glaube ich viele faktoren sprache et cetera
okay also vielleicht nochmal kurz nachzubilden wie wie das läuft also normalerweise läuft jetzt mal gleich dann über zu leiten was ihr euch jetzt sozusagen darunter vorstellt
es geht um das herausfinden also man spricht mit denen die für so ein gespräch da haben die wahrscheinlich eine fragebogen immer so eine liste von sachen die sie abchecken und all diese ganzen ergebnisse notieren sie dann in,
excel-listen soll ich das richtig ja.
Ok und dann bauen sie sich quasi so eine kleine private datenbank um diesen fall auf da fällt dann natürlich letzten endes auch die meldung bei raus wenn ihr herausgefunden haben wann die erkrankt sind et cetera.
Und dann ja mehr andere das dann immer weiter dass man eben auf andere leute stößt wobei man ja dann auch wiederum vielleicht überschneidungen mit anderen
recherchen hat also es kann ja auch durchaus sein dass sie ein anderer mitarbeiter an einem fall arbeitet und das ist dieser
diese beiden fälle sind sich aber so nah dass dann eigentlich auch wieder die gleichen leute erreicht werden also es sind ja alles ganz komplexe netzwerke die dabei entstehen.
Diese meldung die dann letzten endes beim r k i gemacht werden muss das ist ja meldepflichtig krankheit wir wollen ja diese statistiken haben etcetera hast du dann einblick wie das erfolgt.
Also soweit ich weiß gibt es da aktuell schon ein system also das ist geistert ja immer die meldung von dem fax irgendwie rum aber ich glaube soweit ich weiß gibt es ist das nicht mehr fax basiert.
Nee nee das haben die in einer woche dann sein gelassen aber das gab's wirklich faxt also das.
Ok ok cool interessante info.
Wie das wie das aktuell genau läuft weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht es ist auf jeden fall so dass da aktuell wohl an der schnittstelle gearbeitet wird sodass man das sozusagen wiederum komplett automatisiert machen kann
und wir natürlich auch jetzt schon irgendwie an uns anschauen wie wir da potenziell irgendwie mit mit rankommen aber das sind alles bisschen zukunftsmusik wir haben uns jetzt erstmal auf die
auf die themen sozusagen fokussiert die jetzt die kernarbeitsnorm zeit von den einzelnen gesundheitsamt mitarbeiter.
Was es nicht gibt wenn ich das richtig verstehe ist was man sich ja vielleicht so vorstellen könnte also
du wie ich aber auch wir sind ja immer so eine wie soll ich sagen in so eine selbstverständlichkeit wolke was so digitale automatisierung betrifft man kann sich ja heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen das komplexe vorgänge nicht in irgendeiner form computergestützt sind schon gar nicht wenn es ebenso,
und zeit relevant ist wie hier aber es gibt in dem sinne da kein gesundheitsamt betriebssystem eine software mit der alle arbeiten wo alle fälle drin landen und wo man diesen ganzen kontakte nachvollzieht sondern es wird
quasi in anführungsstrichen von hand aber schon mit digitalen werkzeugen gemacht aber dann eben sowas generisches wie excel.
Also ich weiß nicht kollege von mir hat man das zitat geprägt egal welches stück stoff der du baust deine hauptkonkurrenten ist excel also es ist.
Das ist das ein bisschen traurig aber es ist halt da ist auch die realität und ich meine viele viele firmen haben irgendwie sich damit einfach dann noch erstmal produktiver gemacht zu dem was sie vorher hatten also das ist ja ich mag das immer nicht so diskutiert sozusagen anschauen.
Würde würde ich auch gar nicht so dargestellt wird weil es ja auch klar ich meine dass das schöne an diesen stretch ist das sind halt im prinzip universelle datenbanken die man extrem frei gestalten kann und der vorteil ist man kann sie extrem freigeschalten und der nachteil ist man kann sie extrem frei gestalten
also wo man eben viel flexibilität hat da kann man eben auch sehr viele fehler machen und die werden natürlich auch gemacht von jetzt problem mit der software selber mal ganz
gesehen aber ich denke dass gerade so datenbanken auch eine der bereiche sind im computing wo so die problematik.
Wie leicht kriegt man die user wirklich zu dieser speicherung der daten sehr schwierig ist weil er der aufwand der software technische aufwand ist immer relativ hoch und,
ja über die jahre verschiedene ansätze hier nur so.
Was weiß ich so so datenbanken zu machen die von vornherein so visuell daherkommen mit irgendwelchen karten prinzipien und so wo wo jeder auch selber designer seine eigene datenbank sein kann und auch wenn das dann eben bisschen bestimmten punkt hilft.
Stößt man dann eben irgendwann an so eine komplexitätsgrad ab der sich das dann eben auch nicht mehr komplexer gestalten lässt oder
leckere dinge nicht mehr so ohne weiteres abbilden lassen und,
und da ist dann halt irgendwie eine grenze und dann erleben wir glaube ich oft und das ist ja hier auch wieder so ein beispiel dass er eben so eine teil digitalisierung schon sehr wohl stattgefunden hat man das eben so in dieser flexibilität in dem rahmen wie man hatte
das gemacht hat aber in dem moment wo dann einfach mal krassere anforderungen kommen also genauer schneller flexibler etcetera mehr meter daten dann
kommt das eben schnell an seine grenze
und das ist jetzt im prinzip genau der punkt wo ihr jetzt mal reinkommt und das hat aber auch den vorteil dass ihr eigentlich aber auch nur gegen excel ankämpfen müssen und nicht gegen irgendeine andere software die bestimmte dinge schon mal so und so gemacht hat.
Naja jein also es gibt natürlich irgendwie software also das ist jetzt nicht so dass wir dass wir jetzt die ersten werden die sich darüber gedacht haben so hey was könnte man jemand beim gesundheitsamt produktiver arbeiten.
Es gibt andere software die aber dann üblicherweise.
Einfach viel mehr machen will das ist dann so eher so allgemein ich will nicht sagen also ich stell dir arzt arztpraxis software vorne aber einfach software die die viel größeren fokus größerer fokus und ein schwieriger begriff aber.
Breiteres breiteres spektrum an features abdecken möchte die kostet halt also zum einen dann jetzt natürlich auch schon geld.
Punkt ist aber es gibt halt irgendwie zu zwei zwei hauptpunkte die warum die noch nicht bei gesundheitsämtern im einsatz sind das erste ist das jetzt gerade in bezug auf diese fall nach verfolgung einfach das problem bisher nicht da war also da gab's irgendwie mal.
Einen fall von irgendeiner meldepflichtig krankheit hier und mal da.
Ja so bisschen masern kriegt man auch noch mit excel hin ja.
Genau und das andere ist halt das einfach natürlich auch in die digitalisierung von gesundheitsämtern wahrscheinlich auf der prioritätenliste des bundesfinanzministeriums etwas weiter hinten steht also da ist jetzt auch nicht gerade mit geld nach denen geworfen worden um solche projekte.
Zu starten.
Okay gut aber das ist jetzt so die situation in der ihr seid was was ist denn jetzt euer ansatz also was was was ist denn schon entstanden und was was soll eigentlich noch entstehen und was kann dabei rauskommen für alle.
Also ausgangspunkt ist ja sozusagen die notwendigkeit der recherche auf der gesundheitsamt seite und dann nach verfolgung oder dieses tracking in gewisser weise und
der also wie wie wie kommen die an die information und das ist halt bisher einfach ein pool prinzip ja sitzt also jemand da und muss halt pro tag dreißig personen zweimal am tag.
Anrufen und dann hat er eigentlich den ganzen tag zu tun und kann nichts anderes mehr machen und der muss halt diese leute auch alle anrufen wenn bei denen alles in ordnung ist.
Aber es ist ja im prinzip erst der zweite schritt der erste schritt ist doch das ein infiziert der überhaupt erstmal auftritt also neu ins spiel kommt.
Da kommt jemand mit einem testergebnis und da haben wir dann sozusagen die persönlichen also die kontakte informationen zumindest von jemandem oder die müssen halt recherchiert werden
stecke ich in dem prozess steige ich nicht drin aber bei uns ist sozusagen der ausgangspunkt es gibt zumindest irgendwie eine telefonnummer den kann man anrufen.
Dann wird kriegt ihr jetzt quasi gesagt also pass auf wir könnten dich jetzt jeden tag anrufen zweimal wollen wir aber nicht,
du könntest dir ein zugang in diesem system bekommen und kannst sozusagen über eine einladung dann in dieses dich in diesem system registrieren
das macht derjenige der führt dann füllt dann nochmal so eine initialführung gebogen aus indem er nochmal sich selbst so ein bisschen klassifiziert der oder diejenige,
um dann,
eingestuft zu werden also wenn jemand zum beispiel aus medizinischen bereich kommt wird es irgendwie leicht anders behandelt als jemand der jetzt eben einfach nur maurer ist oder so.
Beziehungsweise risikopatienten die können da darüber auch relativ leicht identifiziert werden und der letzte schritt in diesem in dieser registrierung ist eben dass das angeben der kontakte in den letzten
paar tagen also üblicherweise ist dann irgendwie das test datum minus eins zwei tage oder so und man muss halt ist halt eigentlich verpflichtet so gut es geht,
aufzuschreiben mit wem man da kontakt hat und gibt quasi diese personen an kann jetzt halt sowas sagen ich wenn ich jetzt die person genau kenne kann ich sehr detaillierte angaben dazu machen unter umständen habe ich eine telefonnummer.
Kandida eintragen oder ich sag halt irgendwie das war ich glaube war beim bäcker oder ich.
Ich weiß dass ich eine bestimmte person getroffen habe kann die aber nicht genauer identifizieren oder sowas dann landen diese diese personen alle in dem system und müssen jetzt eigentlich alle von dem gesundheitsamt mitarbeiter,
ständig also recherchiert werden erstmal initial beziehungsweise dann
nachverfolgt werden über ihren gesundheitszustand die wir werden alle in zweiwöchige quarantäne gepackt und.
Das gesundheitsamt ist eigentlich verpflichtet da täglich anzurufen mindestens zweimal.
Und die idee ist eigentlich folgende dass wir diesen diesen diesen dieses prinzip ja das gesundheitsamt.
Tritt den hinterher um die informationen zu bekommen umdrehen in einem die leute werden in die lage versetzt die informationen einfach selbst in dieses system einzutragen.
Und wir machen es ich will gar nicht sagen wie das da wie großartig logik dahinter ist aber es gibt so ein bestimmte kriterien die so einen fall
für das gesundheitsamt zu einem machen bei dem sie irgendwas tun müssen also aktiv tun müssen ja also wenn jemand zum beispiel über mehrere tage einfach fieber einträgt sagt ich hätte jetzt irgendwie neununddreißig fieber vierzig fieber und so weiter und so fort dann wird das mindestens
eigentlich trivial das irgendwie herauszufinden aus der datenbank und dann wird,
gibt es eine spezielle ansicht für die gesundheitsamtes sortiert nach der priorität eben an in anbetracht dieser anomalien wie wir das nennen also jemand hat sich.
A zwei tage sein tagebuch nicht ausgefüllt jemand hat hohes fieber gehabt jemand hat das erste mal ein charakteristisches symptom angegeben solche dinge.
Oder die kombination aus dem ich habe hohes fieber gehabt ich habe mich zwei tage nicht gemeldet,
da sollte man jemand anrufen aber alleine das reicht halt um die arbeitsbelastung bei den gesundheitsamtes zur reduzieren weil die die ganzen.
Den ganzen,
normalen fälle wo das jetzt eben vielleicht einfach okay ich habe kontakt gehabt ich habe gar keine symptome ist eigentlich nichts passiert über zwei wochen dass sie da nicht ständig hinterher treten müssen oder die leute nicht erreichen manchmal ist es einfach so versucht jemanden anzurufen zehn leute anzurufen und die sind alle nicht zu erreichen ja dann,
was dann zieht sich das so ein bisschen wie paket zu stellen das größte problem ist jemand ist nicht da so.
Das ist eigentlich grob zusammengefasst schon alles also das ist.
Ich stecke wieder in die kerbe die ich vorne wie meinte oder kurz angesprochen habe es ist gar nicht irgendwie jetzt hoch technische digitalisierung in irgendeiner form sondern es ist so der einfach nur durch diese umdreht umdrehen dieses kontakt
prinzips na das können wir sparen die halt einfach einen haufen zeit und.
Was die natürlich irgendwie ganz nett finden die gesundheitsamt mitarbeiter ist das die die software jetzt auch über den zeitraum einfach den jetzt der letzten wochen so gebaut ist.
Das ist einfach an deren prozesse sozusagen angewiesen.
Angepasst oder ist es einfach ich weiß gar nicht wie man sicher dass das jetzt jedes gesundheitsamt irgendwie die exakt gleichen anforderungen hätte wie wir zum beispiel erzählen wie lange da wie lange wann muss zum beispiel diese anomalie getriggert werden dass jemand seinen eintrag nicht gemacht hat
dein tagebuch eintrag so da geht's wahrscheinlich von gesundheitsamt gesundheitsamt macht das irgendwie jedes ein bisschen anders aber das sind halt so sachen.
Ja alles konfiguriert.
Das kann man dann eben anpassen das ist gar kein problem aber generell so dieses ines für den mitarbeiter in das system gehen sofort sehen was sind eigentlich die wichtigen dinge die ich tun muss also die
jetzt auch dann effekt haben wenn ich da anrufe und einfach der ganzen sache viel leichter herr werden und.
Dann eben einfach zeit zu sparen und dann.
Potenziell auch jetzt gerade für die zukunft wenn es jetzt darum geht dass wir alle irgendwie so ein bisschen zum in ein normales leben zurückkommen das dann in dem fall wenn sowas auftaucht eben wie einfach sehr schnell und sehr effizient einfach diese sachen wieder einkreisen können,
wo wo solche fälle auftauchen das ist so die idee.
Jetzt ist ja so dass wir ja alle wissen wenn wenn's hoffe erstmal läuft und was sinnvolles tut dann fallen einem ja auch immer gleich noch tausend sachen ein die man dann auch noch reinbauen könnte,
was denkst du wohin sich das potenziell entwickeln könnte.
Ich habe ich habe da ehrlich gesagt zur zeit sind wir da so ein bisschen in so einem würde ich sagen tunnelmodus aber wir würden jetzt halt gerne mannheim ist in testbetrieb will eigentlich nächste woche damit einen start gehen.
Dass wir das erstmal quasi auf die straße kriegen und das ist so der der der haupt.
Fokus gerade eben wir schauen natürlich darüber hinaus links und rechts ne also was ist was ist mit dem mit der mit der meldung an das ist was was eigentlich.
Wir haben eine detail genaue übersicht die tagtäglich wer da als neue infizierte person sozusagen auftaucht sei es als
index fall wie die das nennen also sprich jemand macht separat vom system ein testergebnis macht einen test kriegt ein ergebnis und wird dann eingetragen oder jemand war ein kontakt und stellt sich nach drei tagen raus so okay da hat.
Charakteristischen thomé und dann eben auch einen test.
Da haben wir genau die informationen wann die waren das alles passiert wie es wäre also ein leichtes des irgendwie irgendwie zuzuspielen der der das irgendwie statistisch auswerten möchte.
Solche dinge es gibt natürlich auch jetzt dann überlegungen wir beobachten die die die tracing app also sprich diese diese kontakt nach verfolgung die dann die der bürger in seinem telefon durch die gegend trägt ob ob das irgendwie sinnvoll dann eben.
Möglichkeiten gibt das mit zu integrieren also einfach bei der kontakt mitteilung dann in dem fall wenn jemand infiziert ist ob das hilft nur wir sind auch so ein bisschen vorsichtig weil aktuell bewegen wir uns eigentlich auf sehr sicherem,
datenschutztag weil das infektionsschutz gesetz und sehr genau vorgibt was wir da irgendwie speichern dürfen und was nicht und was da für daten abzufragen sind weil.
Zumindest die die körpertemperatur die man da eingibt tagtäglich ne das sind ja im endeffekt gesundheitsdaten da machen wir eigentlich nur das was die was die was die gesundheit tun.
Alle alle weitergehende integration würde jetzt natürlich erstmal diese diese diese baustelle aufreißen diese fragen.
Deswegen ist da so ein bisschen vorsicht gerade eben bei da will man natürlich irgendwie auch kein kein mist bauen.
Dann sparen wir es vielleicht mal anders rum auf ihr seid jetzt mit einem gesundheitsamtes kommenare arbeit in mannheim da
jetzt im idealfall nächste woche losgehen können jetzt haben wir ja noch ich glaube vierhundertsiebenunddreißig weitere gesundheitsämtern die auch noch in frage kommen.
Dir irgendwas bekannt von ähnlichen initiativen.
Das ist eigentlich so aktuell die hauptherausforderung für die leute die bei uns so dieses diese öffentlichkeitsarbeit machen
gesundheitsämtern landkreisen aufgehangen sind das heißt da ist jetzt auch der effekt den wir durch den den hackathon sehen dass das quasi bei der bundesregierung quasi bekannt ist das projekt ist jetzt nicht so ein großer leider aktuell noch
weil das eben nicht so von oben nach unten runter reden kann also da fließt schon informationen aber es kann jetzt keiner sagen hier nimm mal bitte alle diese app,
das heißt da sprechen wir halt hauptsächlich momentan erstmal im in baden-württembergischen raum das liegt halt eben daran dass jetzt mannheim also die der die leitung des gesundheitsamt.
Bei den ihnen bekannten anderen gesundheitsämtern irgendwie dafür auch die werbetrommel rühren also da findet so eine art
also so ein word quasi darüber statt ne also ist halt so eher informell ich habe jetzt hier in ich selbst sitze in dresden und ich habe jetzt hier den dresdner gesundheitsamt mal eine e-mail geschrieben ich habe die versucht telefonisch zu erreichen aber die haben verständlicherweise jetzt anderes zu tun,
aber dass da vielleicht dass wir irgendwie es schaffen da die die einfach die aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen ich glaube jetzt
in der aktuellen situation ist wahrscheinlich auch die die aufmerksamkeit darauf vielleicht wieder ein stückchen zurück gegangen weil man jetzt sagt damit der anzahl der fälle die wir jetzt gerade eben haben kommen wir ja wieder eigentlich relativ gut klar
aber also.
Das kann sich ja schnell wieder ändern und,
gerade in baden-württemberg sieht ja derzeit auch noch naja also das ist sozusagen im prinzip so der hotspot also bayern vor allem aber eben auch.
Also der süden ist sagen wir mal noch deutlich mehr gebeutelt ganz klar weil letztlich wurde das virus ja auch aus dem süden eingeschleppt dann schlägt sich das natürlich dort
am nächsten wieder aber es gibt halt durchaus auch die herausforderung eben auch vor allem schnell reagieren zu können und ich denke.
Kontrolle eines ausbruchs hängt erheblich davon ab wie schnell man dann jetzt die leute hier rein bekommt und diese corona warn-app sorgt halt dafür dass leute überhaupt erstmal als infiziert gemeldet werden und wenn halt eine andere software dazu beitragen kann.
Dass das nicht auch unmittelbar zu einer überlastung eines gesundheitsamt,
führt er hat das quasi auch bei einer hohen belastung immer noch eine kapazität frei ist die in der lage ist auch noch ein weiteren ausbruch mit.
Kontrollieren zu können ist ja eigentlich schon eine ganze menge gewonnen.
Vielleicht nochmal eine nachfrage meintest ja auch dass es ein guter hinweis so was man so statistisch daraus gewinnen könnte so ein erkenntnissen ist ja schon mal was durch den kopf gehen lassen was was da vielleicht interessante erkenntnisse sein könnten.
Wie gesagt ehrlich gesagt nicht weil wir jetzt sozusagen hauptsächlich an den.
Woanders ja.
Der kopf ist gerade woanders ja nee eigentlich nicht.
Okay aber man könnte ja zumindest krankheitsverlauf sind ja relativ klar erfasst ja also das das das liefert ja mal eine extrem gut zeit aufzeigt dich aufgelösten krankheitsverlauf.
Also ich meine es wenn man sich dann die die die fälle die oder die nachverfolgen fälle die dann im system waren.
Dann vielleicht auch abgeschlossen sind mal anschaut dann kann man wahrscheinlich irgendwie rückschlüsse über also für okay welche leute im eigenen umfeld sind denn vielleicht irgendwie risiko,
so was ganz besonders statistik der weiß papa wahrscheinlich mehr als ich beziehungsweise ich du hast wahrscheinlich auch den den podcast vom vom christian thorsten der immer darauf hinweist dass es so problematisch ist leute in eine richtige studie zu bekommen weil man dann so so so
na wie soll ich sagen so vor gefärbt auswählt weil bestimmte leute die infiziert waren die niemand zu einer studie nicht mehr teilweise wissen die hatten schon und so weiter und dann
das hat das die ergebnisse genau und in dieser fall verfolgung software hat man eigentlich so,
das ist also das ist jetzt keine keine kann natürlich auch sicherheit auch gefärbt aber es würde zumindest irgendwie vielleicht helfen sich das mal anzuschauen was da jemand damit tun will das ist im endeffekt in in der in der,
in der hand der gesundheitsämtern was die dann daraus was dir dann daraus machen aber es ist auf jeden fall ein punkt den man den man vielleicht langfristig mal anschauen sollte ja.
Eure software nehme ich mal an ist im wesentlichen erstmal wird basiert.
Jawohl also server komponente und ein ein frontend freundin.
Das heißt die leute benutzen erstmal ein webbrowser um das alles auszufüllen ist da schon übernächste schritt nachgedacht werden ich mein das naheliegende ist natürlich dann gleich apps zu bauen et cetera.
Ja auch hier das thema also es gibt eigentlich nichts was in dieser applikation danach schreit wirklich eine native app zu benötigen und dann bin ich eigentlich immer was,
persönlich jetzt freund davon zu sagen wir brauchen einfach lieber eine web-applikation vernünftig und die funktioniert ja doch auf dem telefon vernünftig weil dann habe ich nicht das problem dass ich irgendwie betriebssystem irgendwie nicht bedienen kann oder was auch immer also.
Wie möglich sollte das der ganze jahr eben sein.
Ja gut ich meine wenn mit einer app hätte man natürlich auch flexiblere möglichkeit die leute dann auch zu erinnern also das waren notifications macht.
Ja ok ok gut davon stimmt.
Also na gut aber kann mir auch gut vorstellen erstmal geht es natürlich darum alles.
Ich schreib das mal als feature request.
Startet da fällt mir bestimmt noch einige.
Ja doch das interessant ist gut.
Weil das wäre jetzt sozusagen das was ich so erwarten würde ich meine muss ja auch davon ausgehen die leute sind auch gerade krank so ne.
Na ja.
Wenn du da nichts mit neununddreißig fieber und so.
Lass mal den windows-rechner starten.
Ja genauso oder macht das ding ding und das ist so browser und so ich meine das mag am einen tag sehr einfach vorkommen auf dem anderen ist es dann irgendwie aber auch schon wieder
viel zu viel so wie war denn jetzt die webadresse und so,
wenn du da aber einfach so deine app hast die einfach hochkommen sagst so klingen fünfzehn uhr ist mal wieder zeit fieber zu messen hast du gemacht ja zack
und so also quasi auch so ein bisschen was an die hand gibt als durchführung das musst du machen das musst du machen auch zur auch zum selbstschutz in gewisser hinsicht also es ist ja
dann schon fast eine pflegerische maßnahme.
Können wir auf jeden fall noch einiges vorstellen aber klar wichtig ist vor allem dass hier diese digitalisierung verbessert wird und am ende würde das ja auch bedeuten dass diese meldung vielleicht auch zeit näher durchgeführt werden können also es,
ist ja gerade großes thema wie langsam teilweise meldungen vorgenommen werden manchmal zahlt einfach auch gründe weil eben informationen bisher natürlich auch erstmal
gewonnen werden und dann weiß man halt auch einfach erstmal zwei drei tage später,
aber man will natürlich jetzt verhindern dass weitere verzögerung dadurch entstehen das einfach nur die prozesse zu schwierig oder zu fehleranfällig sind.
Ja haben wir es im prinzip einmal eingepackt eins hast du noch nicht gesagt wie es heißt.
Ja ist mir vorhin auch gerade aufgefallen das projekt heißt karamel also mit uwe von quarantäne und kahane.
Es gibt kein natürlich da findet man den.
Den pitch also die idee dokumentation auch kontaktmöglichkeiten falls jemand irgendwie von gesundheitsämtern zuhört und dass ich gerne mal anschauen möchte wir haben tests zugänge.
Der ganze code ist natürlich irgendwie open source auf dot com slash korane unter der public leistung wie ich jetzt gelernt habe.
Wir haben nicht genommen weil wir gerne hätten dass die die lizenz sozusagen viral ist also sprich dass jemand das unter der gleichen lizenz weiterverwenden nur darf.
Relativ neu das habe ich jetzt auch erst im rahmen dieses dieser ganzen corona aktivitäten gesehen dass es diese lizenz überhaupt erst gibt dass es eine eu public leistungs gibt und die jetzt hier in zunehmenden maße auch von den projekten benutzt wird können wir durchaus vorstellen dass das noch mal ein trend wird.
Ich mache seitdem ich denken kann irgendwie open source software die patrick ich meinte wir haben jetzt die genommen wieso was aber das
passt ja ganz gut also man hat weiterhin alle freiheiten außer dass man eben die software wenn man sie denn verwendet oder einbindet irgendwo dann eben selbst nur unter der gleichen lizenz wieder weiter.
So alles open source heißt das ist einerseits eine einladung für leute dann auch mal nachzugucken und gegebenenfalls noch mit verbesserungen ergänzungen kommentaren sonstiger kritik anzukommen.
Bitte bitte gerne.
Heißt aber auch dass im prinzip wenn jetzt uns hier irgendwelche gesundheitsämtern zuhören,
im prinzip ja auch gleich zugreifen müssen aber jetzt das würde ja nicht bedeutet jetzt muss jetzt jeder anfangen sich selber das zu installieren wie stellt ihr euch denn diese diese diese installation vor im prinzip bräuchte ja jedes gesundheitsamt seine eigene
server instanz eigenes system kann man da irgendeiner form der eine dienstleistung erwarten.
Ja also das ist ein verschiedene themen ich habe im generell.
Wir haben die möglichkeit einfach müde bauen dot container das heißt wenn ein gesundheitsamt das selbst betreiben möchte dann können sie das sie brauchen nichts anderes als eine datenbank und halt irgendwie einen.
Ausführen kann und ein bisschen javascript also die enkel applikation wir bieten aber auch in zusammenarbeit jetzt dann mit,
der telekom die halt also die war so sponsor in dem wir was es virus hackathon genau da bieten wir haben wir bekommen für einen bestimmten,
also menge an an hosting leistungen gewisser weise und arbeiten damit ein paar dienstleistern zusammen die das ganze auch betreiben auf entsprechend
zertifizierter infrastruktur also die
dann eben die anforderungen kommen ja vom vom bundesgesundheitsministerium dann in dem fall auf auf welchen servern solche sachen liegen dürfen und dann gibt's halt irgendwie zertifizierte cloud-umgebungen in denen geht das und,
damit betreiben wir jetzt zum gerade eben mannheim im testbetrieb und dann auch erstmal produktiv und man kann es also quasi von.
Uns beziehungsweise dann dem dienstleister gehostet bekommen oder halt eben selbst betreiben das sind so die zwei optionen.
Also eigentlich ein recht attraktives angebot wenn ich das mal so sagen darf ne also das man im prinzip software gibt's quasi kostenlos und den betrieb auch noch dazu da fragt man sich ja.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht in die vertragsverhandlungen mit mannheim involviert was die was die finanzielle thematik angeht
aber zumindest die die kosten für das hosting die muss man glaube ich schon aufbringen als wir sind ein verein jetzt wenn man verein gegründet um die ganze sache um uns da auch so ein bisschen rechtlich sinnvoll,
jetzt wird jetzt keine firma erstmal gegründet da drumrum weil die das alle irgendwie ehrenamtlich und nebenbei machen.
Okay also es ist sozusagen von euch auch wirklich quasi eine arbeitspensums der stelle und braucht er noch entwickler oder.
Definitiv also das team es hat sich jetzt sehr verändert nach dem hackathon waren viele leute dabei die sind gegangen weil sie.
Keine zeit mehr haben was auch immer sind viele neue leute dazugekommen wissen es gibt aber trotzdem eine recht dünne personaldecke also wenn jemand lust hat sich einzubringen.
Irgendwie im front deines enkel im backend springblut oder was auch immer in jeglicher form einfach bitte.
Oder halt apps auch für die telefone ne.
Natürlich ja wenn wenn da jemand es gibt den also das wenn man das irgendwie bedienen kann und jemand sagt er hätte bock irgendwie ein android-app dafür zu bauen oder ein iphone.
Okay auf de findet man dann wahrscheinlich auch alle notwendigen kontakte oder man quatsch ich direkt auf twitter an ja oli haben wir alles.
Ja vielen dank für die einladung für die gelegenheit hier.
Ja vielen dank für dein engagement und die erklärung hier dann sage ich tschüss und.
Vielen dank fürs zuhören bei weiter geht's mit corona wiki damit pavel da werden wir ein paar weitere zahlen durch quatschen zeitnah und.